[Music]  so if you were headed to work today near  the strip you probably noticed quite a  backup and right now  slow going in that area as well so we've  got a live picture from rtc's fast cams  you can see it now  those cones there out on the road and so  this is on las vegas boulevard between  elvis presley boulevard  and sahara will be down to one lane in  each direction from  seven in the morning till two in the  afternoon and as you can see ongoing  construction  and crews are going to be paving the  road in that area so some options  you can use paradise or sammy davis  junior drive to access the strip  corridor  this project is the first of seven  phases of work along las vegas boulevard  between sahara and the 215.